nato leaders arrived at a historic
summit projecting unity and strength in
the face of a new threat
this conflict in ukraine
is not a regional issue
it's a global struggle between democracy
and autocracy
nato is rewriting its own playbook
boosting battle-ready troop numbers
across its eastern flank and with plans
to vastly increase rapid reaction force
numbers from 40 thousand to three
hundred thousand troops by twenty twenty
three
russia's deadly attack on a shopping
mall in southeast ukraine on monday
foreshadowed this summit
until recently considered a nato partner
russia will for the first time since the
cold war officially be redesignated an
enemy threat
we meet in the midst of the most
serious security crisis we have faced
since the second world war president
zielenski appealed as he does
relentlessly at international events for
more help
he warned the leaders present that
russia's next move may be against one of
them
and nato is determined to do what it can
offering a further package of non-lethal
assistance this defensive alliance
careful not to be seen to be joining the
conflict
but we never wanted to to have
escalation with russia all we want is to
live in peace in europe and therefore we
are making crystal clear that we are
ready to defend ourselves and preparing
all the structures for what we need
the summit began on a high note after an
arms and security agreement was reached
allowing turkey to lift its objection to
bids by sweden and finland to join the
alliance
so sweden and finland attend this summit
as official invitees their membership
bids approved by all 30 leaders to be
ratified by national parliaments in the
coming months turkey said it got what it
wanted well so did nato able to project
both a united and expanded front and
gaining superiority over russia in the
baltic region
president biden announcing an expanded
u.s military presence in europe said the
alliance had never been so galvanized a
major shift to a state of readiness for
whatever turns russian aggression may
yet take
jonah al jazeera madrid
our diplomatic editor james bates joins
me now from the summit in madrid and
james the nato secretary general clearly
laying out the organization's military
plans for the future
military plans for the future in the
coming months and years and for the next
10 years because he's also announced
something called the strategic concept
which is nato's strategy plan going
forward uh designating russia as their
principal threat but also interestingly
saying that there are many challenges
that nato potentially faces and nato
nations face from china but in terms of
the immediate threat with the war in
ukraine they are putting more forces
into the eastern flank of nato into
those countries closest to russia
they're going to make some of those
forces more permanent the us
which is mainly based in poland that is
where it has its battle group that is
going to have uh the largest number of
any nato forces in in poland that's
where there'll be more than any of the
other battle groups and that is the
first permanent headquarters of the us
in one of those countries closest to
russia they are saying that this is an
important day a transformative day for
nato these were the words of the
secretary general
president putin's war against ukraine
has shattered peace in europe
and has created the biggest security
crisis in europe since the second world
war
nato has responded with strength and
unity
and president zielenski's leadership and
courage
are an inspiration to all of us
and of course james u.s president biden
also talking to nato chief stoltenberg
about that inclusion of sweden and
finland appeasing turkey as well do you
get a sense from as you have your ear to
the ground that there is some relief and
that the focus can really be now russia
yes absolutely i think there is relief
they were worried that the turks were
going to continue this it was negotiated
just before the start of this summit
they were worried it would drag on
through the summit i think we now have
had all the big announcements that they
were expecting to have so in addition to
what i told you about that strategic
concept in addition to a reordering of
forces in addition to more forces coming
in from the u.s you have two new nato
members now they're not nato members yet
sweden and finland they're invitee
nations uh they've formally been invited
though in the last few hours and then
there's a process of what's known as
ratification they go around all of the
nato countries and each country has to
formally ratify the two new members in
most countries that involves uh their
national parliaments so 30 countries to
ratify and when that's done nato is no
longer 30 countries it's 32 countries
the two new members then are going to be
members that have pretty sophisticated
military pretty strong military members
that have worked with nato many times in
the past they are nato's closest
partners in fact they've been on nato
missions in the balkans and in
afghanistan in the past james bazer our
diplomatic editor in madrid thanks james